il y avait bien sûr hélène et les
garçons l'heure ils viennent les garçons
c'est citer les grands
c'est alors et d'année des garçons alors
le star de la série hélène nicolas laly
josé bel et bien sûr cricri d'amour
on regarde tout de suite un petit excès
c'est un y avait toujours des bisous en
fait à l'évidence ça se paye chauny
autant
[Musique]
nous sommes un tube ou pas du tout petit
peu nerveux mais ça va je verrai pas
avec vous les filles n'en avait rendez
vous chez le médecin on cri cri d'amour
l'âge - jana
et yat sen la insight qui voulait revoir
pour moi la meilleure scène d'hélène et
les garçons c'est encore la scène culte
de bagarre d'ailleurs ils sont arrivés
que ça s'embrouille et lauriane et les
garçons ils pouvaient voilà
s'embrouiller et regardez c'est la seule
scène qui se passe à l'extérieur vous
allez voir il ya de la violence
nicolas et josé était vraiment hyper
chaud voilà éliminables qui sont là je
recherche la vague là aujourd'hui c'est
parce qu'on méritait mais attendez mais
vous êtes fous quand on essaie de
prévenir istanbul
josé écoute moi est contre nous a menti
sauf à des violeurs messi et a compté
porte quoi j'ai pu décocher coupe
la belle hier matthieu delormeau fans de
séries de sexe masculin
j'avais une question pour christa
primevères également est ce que vous
pourriez me dire pourquoi aujourd'hui
jean-luc azoulay les a tous rappelés
pour tourner notamment de les mystères
de l'amour ils ont quasiment tous
accepté même rochelle qui est aux états
unis est revenue mallaury nataf
pourquoi est-ce que vous rêvez pas vous
dans cette série pour prier il avait
frappé des gens le plein de séries mais
les abeilles de toutes les séries en
tout ce sont les mystères de l'amour
effectivement c'est tout c'est jean
claude petit sa famille finalement elle
se retrouve pour l'as eu une suite
encore mais il m'a demandé en fait mais
jamais mais aujourd'hui j'ai mon âge je
travaille vraiment aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il m'a demandé plusieurs fois et encore
là parce que je crois qu'il va se passer
déjà sur terre et non on n'irait pas non
non je veux pas braquer passer à la télé
qui est passé avant se passer des mois à
faire refaire un projet avec plaisir
mais quelque chose qui voilà qui nous
donne vraiment envie en fait je
fonctionne par envie tu vois là j'ai
fait j'ai vécu de très belles années